こんにちはめ長ですえ今東京にいるんです
けれども
えっと急がなきゃあのですねえ今からえ
海外に行ってき
ます遅れそうです行ってきますちょっと
細かいこと後で話しますとりあえず空港に
向かい
[音楽]
ますはいというわけで空港に向かってます
時刻が深夜の20時50分久々の海外だな
すぎてびっくりさせた方すいません僕も
びっくりしてますちょっと海外にどこに
行くかとかどういう理由で行くかとかは
また後ほど明らかになっていくと思います
がひとまず僕がちょっと編集してて30分
ほど出発が遅れてしまいましたえ今日の
旅行はですねマネージャーさんも同行して
ますロミさんよろしくお願いしますお願い
しますすいません遅刻しちゃって大丈夫
ですこれフライト間に合いますかギリ
ギリわ来
たありがとうございました
よし着きました空港
ですこれ成田空港です羽田です羽田空港
です羽田空港着きまし
たさあサラバ日本ということでいよいよ
出発です初め車長久々の海外ということで
ちょっと緊張しておりますさあどこに行く
と思いますかヒントあげるヒントは日本と
の時差が2時間2時間になってますさあさ
どうでしょう結構日本の縦ライン地球儀
地図で言う縦ラインの近くなのかなと思い
ますあさ海海とかも海とかも見えてますね
結構大きなヒントですさあどこでしょう
なんて言ってる間に目的地に到着しました
さあ降りたとあなたな
[音楽]
知恵はいというわけで着きました着きまし
たがちょっとどうですかねまだどこの国か
バレてない気がしますねちなみに飛行機に
乗ってた時間だけ言う
と9時間です9時間で時差が2時間なんと
なくこうなんか縦のライン付近かなって
いう気はしてると思いますがどうでしょう
僕はちなみに初めて来た国ですはいじゃ
ちょっと目的ちゃんとあってきてますこれ
をするってい目的があってえと海外に来
てるので目的をしっかりこなしていきたい
と思いますじゃ移動しよっ
かお
[音楽]
すげえちょっと移動してビーチの近くに来
まし
たヒントですね海があるということです
ただあの皆さん1つだけ勘違いしないで
欲しいのが遊びに来てるわけじゃありませ
んちゃんと目的があってここに来ています
のではいあの遊んでると思ったらお間違い
ですうわすげえ海来た海来まし
[音楽]
たビーチに来ました
すげえめちゃくちゃ天気入ってみよう
砂浜わすごい全然アジアの人がいないザ
海外って感じですね本当にさあ皆さんここ
がどこか分かりましたでしょうかもう
そろそろ言っていいでしょう私はめ社長
ただいま時差が2時間そして東京から飛行
機で9
時間オーストラリアに来て
ますあめっちゃ瞳が気になるはい私はです
ねオーストラリアのシドニーに来てます初
オーストラリアですよもうちゃんと日本だ
と飲めなそうなジュースも買いました
いただき
[音楽]
ますああすごいなこれがオーストラリアか
海
広あ皆さん勘違いしないでくださいあのま
遊びに来てるわけじゃない本当にちょっと
目的がってきてるので目的はあの後々
分かると思うんですけれども結構あの衝撃
的な目的で僕は今オーストラリアに来て
ますさらに衝撃的なのが
え日帰りで帰ります日帰りオーストラリア
シドニーです
今もっとゆっくりしたかったもっと
ゆっくりしたかったんですけどもちょっと
あの忙しくてちょっと忙しいというか帰っ
てからも別の予定があるので日帰りで
オーストラリアなんと0泊3日の旅です
そんな弾丸でオーストラリアに来てるので
ちょっと本当に目的の遂行だけねしっかり
やっていきたいと思うのでな遊んでる暇は
ない早速次の場所に行きましょうここは
マンリービーチというビーチらしいです
気温がちょうどいいです
なんか子供がハンドスピナーをここに
ぶつけてカンカン言って
ます木切ってる
[音楽]
木
お昼ご飯ですフィッシュ&チップス
アン
ハンバーガー
でかめっちゃでかいいただき
ます
うんうこれがオーストラリアンサイズか
いや絶対大きいのよめくちゃ大きいのよ
オーストラリアといえばビーフのイメージ
がありますねこれがオーストラリアさんの
お肉
[音楽]
かうまいフィッシュアンドチップスも
いただきますバーベキューソースかけます
うわうま
そうフィッシュ&チップスってでも
イギリスの料理じゃないっけ
オーストラリアも主流なのかもフイン
オーストラリアえそうなんだタルタル
ソースもかきよ
もうカロリー爆弾いただきます
うま俺がイギリスで留学した時に通ってた
フィッシンとチップスのお店より
[音楽]
美味しい
るお様でし
た次はフェリーに乗って移動したいと思い
ます普通に街中にフェリー乗り場があり
ましたすげえ普通になんか駅の改
みたいよし乗ります
おお
でけえテラスにしました
[音楽]
すごいあロビさんお疲れ様ですお疲れ様
です席がいいの
かったあそこの左走ってきていです
[音楽]
かここも座れるっぽいのでここにしまし
たさあ行てき
[音楽]
ます
着きまし
たはいフェリー到着しました寒い船乗っ
てると風が冷たくて寒かったですね
ちょっと長袖で来てきて良かったです出
てるといんですけど太陽出てないともう
ちょっと寒いですねオーストラリアはい
もうオーストラリアシドニーといえばここ
みたいな場所がありましてこれがハバー
ブリーチそしてもう形がすごいですよね
こちらオペラハウスですね名前聞いたこと
ある人多いんじゃないかな形がすごい
かっこいい建物があってもう人もかなり
たくさんいらっしゃいますはいあるんだけ
あのわせてくださいせっかく来たんでね見
に行きましょうただ目標もやんないと
ちゃんとね行き
ますオペラハウス前まで来ましたすごいね
この登る階段とかもめっちゃおしゃれなん
だよな全体的にかっこいいここら辺
シドニーの公園です入口かっこよなんか
書いて
[音楽]
ある
ホ何言っとんねんなんか海外ってこういう
公園1つとってもかっこいいよね行き
ましょうかこの公園とかはね結構なぜ私が
オーストラリアのシドに来たかちょっと
目的遂行のためにはいい場所かもしれませ
ん
[音楽]
ねなんてのかなん
だちょっと座りましょうか
ああいいなあ海外すみてえ
ああこれがシドの香りか帰りたく
ねはいそろそろ言いましょうか僕がなぜ
オーストラリアのシドニーに来ているのか
実ははですねあのいろんな場所を観光し
たり歩いたりなんか船乗ったりはめさん
ちょ待ってくださいオーストラリア遊びに
来てるだけじゃないですか観光してるだけ
じゃないですかて思った人いると思います
が
目的同時並行してます実は同地並行して
おりまして私がこのシドニーに何のために
来たかと言います
とこちらポケモンGOのためですめっちゃ
現地の子供たちが僕を見てるまこの俺が
海外に行く理由なんでもうこれぐらいしか
ないでしょポケモンGOのために来ました
だってさオーストラリアにしか出ない
ポケモンとかいるんですよガルーラとか
結構ね日本だと手に入らないポケモン
捕まえたりだとかあと交換のために距離
稼ぎたいんですね交換するポケモン同士の
距離が長ければ長いほどいいのでなるべく
オーストラリアで大量のポケモン捕まえ
たりもうやるべきことはたくさんあります
オーストラリアさんのカレオとかも
羨ましいでしょうはいあのねポケモン号車
に来てますなんかねポケモン号するんだっ
たら初めて来る場所でやりたいなっていう
のとあとその1日で買いなきゃいけない
から割と近場いや全然近場じゃないけど
スケジュール的に行きそうなのが
オーストラリアということで今回
オーストラリアでポケモンGO死に来まし
たでねポケモンGOも進化しましてね俺
オーストラリア楽しく今観光し歩いてる
だけなんですけども結構ポケモンも捕まえ
てますポケモGOププによってこれやばい
んすよ皆さん使ってますポケモGOププが
あればなんと旅行しながら歩いてるだけで
もポケモンが自動に捕まりますこれなんと
あのボタンを押す必要とかもなく持ってる
だけで自動でモンスターボール投げて
くれるんですよ野生のポケモンになんで
ただ俺オーストラリアで観光してるだけだ
と思ったでしょ自動でポケモン捕まえまっ
てましたあの時もこの時もオペラハウスに
向かってる時もなのでこの画面水にも
ハンズフリーで持ってるだけでいいんです
よ何にも押す必要もない実はもう目的遂行
され続けています他に自動でポケストップ
を回してくれてるのでもう俺すごいよ
モンターボールだと自動で投げれるんです
けども設定でねスーパーボールとハイパー
ボールにも帰ることができてそれもね
ボタン押すことによって捕まえることが
できるというもうこれあればねもう何にも
気にせず普通に旅行楽しみながらでも
ポケモン語が遊べますはいもうはい今今
もう捕まえた捕まえたなのであの別にあの
俺観光したいわけじゃないのでポケモン
捕まえに来てますというわけで今日1杯は
ちょっとポケモンGOガテラに観光軽くし
ていこうと思います普通逆だよなもう
ちょっとオーストラリア満喫しますあ違っ
たポケモンGO満喫し
ますおいおい
おいよしよしよしさんこれオーストラリア
ですごい有名なハイトパークって言って
結構ポケモンGOも遊ばれてるみたいです
よえそうなんめっちゃ綺麗です
[音楽]
ねめた違う違うこっち
こっちどう考えた携帯じゃなくてガルーラ
とか出ちゃっすごいなんかいやめっちゃ
綺麗す本当にいいすねおトゲチックが出て
きまし
たよしよしこれでオーストラリアさんの
トゲゲットですいやこれかっこよくない
オーストラリアのシドニーのポケモンマジ
で捕まくるからねあえと光も楽しみながら
ですけどもはいや最高だねこの景色で
ポケモン語はたまんない
[音楽]
ね
うま闇オブ闇
ちょっと歩きつかれました観光と言ってて
もポケモンGOずっとやってるんで歩き
続けてるわけなので結構ね朝から歩き続け
て足が疲れたのでちょっと休憩してます
休憩終わったらポケモンGOまた頑張り
ます来た路面電車オーストラリアの路面
電車に乗ってみようと思いますいやこれで
一気にこうオーストラリアシドの街並みが
楽しみそうですね楽しみ
[音楽]
です
おお
すげえ
めっちゃねねいいっすよ
[音楽]
ね
めさガルラでますよ捕まえまし
たはい今欲しいのがガルーラとドリのこの
姿とあとねペラップとかも出ますねそこら
辺ちょっとたくさん捕えてきたいですねき
ましたり
いやめちゃくちゃはったな曇ってきたん
ですけどもまたペキが良くなってきました
美しい最高の景色
ニュークうわめさ
これシドシド大学すバカでかいめっちゃ
きれやばいすマジ
でねはめさんあすいませんあこれですよね
なてでかいすねそしてなん
と色違いが捕まりましたオーストラリア
さんの軸ですめっちゃロックポケモンGO
プラスプラスで捕まえましたこれ自動的に
捕まえてくれるのでもう知らない間に
色違いポケモンとかもたまに捕まってるの
でちょっとちょっと幸せいやマジでかっこ
いいああ
すげえうわあ
すげえ
[音楽]
めっちゃいいなここずっとゲットして
ますはじめさんこれシドニーパークす
めちゃくちゃ
でかい
あれはじめさんどうしましたはじめ
さんあポケモンこやってましたやっぱ
いいっすね日本だといないポケモン出る
だけでテンション上がってずやっちゃい
ますねかなり墓取りました今回途中から
ちょっと夢中になってたんですけども
ずっとポケモンGO触ってたわけでもなく
自動で捕まえてくれるポケモンGOププを
使ってオーストラリアかなり満喫できたと
思いますいやこれすごいすねこの公園いる
とあ地球って丸いんだって実感しますね
違う違うこれのただの坂ですあ坂ですか
[音楽]
はい
はいもうかなり日が沈んできましたねもう
くれちゃうよ日が驚きなのが
オーストラリア結構日が沈むのが遅いです
ね19時なのにまだこんなに明るい
オーストラリア日帰り0泊3日なので
そろそろ空港に向かわなきゃいけないので
空港に向かいますいいところだった
なただいまはいというわけで
オーストラリアから帰ってきましまし
た最強に弾丸でしたね0泊3日の
オーストラリアごめんなさいあの帰りもう
ほぼ意識失いかけてて飛行機でももう
ゆっくりしてちょっと撮影するの忘れてる
ぐらい本当疲れてたんですけどもえ弾丸で
オーストラリアに行ってもう旅行というか
観光がてらにめちゃくちゃオーストラリア
のポケモン捕まえられましためっちゃ便利
じゃないですか最近はねポケモンGO
プラスプラスあれば普通にこうやって旅行
して歩いてるだけでポケモンがポンポン
捕まるっていうめっちゃ優れたアイテムが
あるので是非ねどこか旅行に行くとか遠く
に行くよって人はぜひやってみてください
僕が許される範囲で一番遠くの国は
オーストラリアぐらいだったのでえ今回は
オーストラリアに行きましたが時間があれ
ば次は右でお会いしましょうじゃ
[音楽]
な
H